uh
all right so your album is out and um
it's been out for it's been out for a
while now yeah july 3rd
yeah um hey what's up with the [ __ ]
this [ __ ] methodical
taylor gang album that i've heard music
that was supposed to be on
for like the last eight years of my life
like what is going on is that ever gonna
i think everybody just started putting
out
like this [ __ ] like singly first just to
build that back up because you know we
did an
uh one before a volume one yeah but that
was more like a tape
yeah wasn't there supposed to be like an
actual album
yeah but that was like that was like the
tape yeah it was the tape but
we're we're working on the album now but
it's just like everybody start doing
their own
so who is like because i i know like
once people are taylor gang you know
it's usually
everything and you know everything's
kosher but like who's officially
taylor gang now like official like who's
on the label now
because you don't see like i don't see
juicy j banging taylor gang like you
used to you know what i'm saying
i mean you know [ __ ] happens
so juicy j's not taylor gang anymore i
mean like you said once you taylor gang
you taylor gang man you know we
i'll be seeing you know people still be
wearing their chains
and stuff like that do you get the chain
back once they leave the crew it's like
hey yo
this is yours as far as as long as there
was only one circumstance that that
happened
you had to get the chain back i didn't
have to get it back who got whose chain
got taken back
i ain't gonna get into all that i mean
come on man no that's cool
was it uh somebody like bigger
uh i ain't gonna get him too long
i you know i mean for me once i once i
rep it i rip it and i'm here
does the chain have to get taken back
i'll take a guess i'll be like
probably like 14 maybe it was back
wow 15. you know what i mean
you know sometimes business stuff don't
work out for people
and it doesn't necessarily have to mean
was it uzi give me the chain back what
did you do
i don't even know but it like give me
the chain back type of deal
you know what i'm saying it's not like a
because i heard you don't give me that i
heard uzi was close to being taylor gang
yeah i mean dj drama in them is family
so yeah you know
so uzi got his chainsaw lake is family
you know what i'm saying
uh don cannon his family shout out to
don cannon yeah
all right well um yeah
yeah man you know like i said once it's
taylor gang it's always taylor gang
especially with me
it's still taylor gang no i'm gonna say
because that that was i feel like that
was the only exception of things i
thought that got kind of sketchy
publicly
where it felt like you guys like it was
like a weird split i feel like everybody
else is just kind of like
yeah i mean it's different when it's you
know
i guess it's different because we
haven't really like parted ways with
like no women
like rappers or you know i mean stuff
like that so i guess it was probably
kind of like a different thing
right right right when you part ways
like that and they got to say what they
got to say anyway yeah
i feel like no matter what like ty is
going to always be
terry being affiliated burner will
always be taylor getting affiliated to
some capacity like
even if now when you speak of affiliated
that's more like it you know what i mean
it's it's people that's like you know
there's like a difference between being
signed to the label right and then just
being
yeah just being the homies of
you know what i'm saying for sure you're
still popping i still support you and do
all of that
but i just in my my years of dealing
with people i just know some things that
i just be like yeah i know what's up
with you still what's up though
you know what i'm saying